make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I just saw best man like I was
just watching best man with Mariah that
movie's really good or actually I'm
ready to watch the second one but I have
to record this audio I recorded it the
first time and it turns out I recorded
it through the bike the microphone on my
on my laptop on my Mac Pro and so I
screwed it up anyway okay so getting
into Batman the the grim Knight this is
actually kind of interesting because
Snyder usually plays these things pretty
close to the vest
and it's kind of a change of pace to
introduce like a one shot I mean he did
that with like the origins of the the
various you know villains from Dark
Knights metal so I guess it kind of
makes sense to keep the trend going but
before that there weren't really any one
shots right like court of owls night of
owls in game death of the family it was
all kind of contained and like the
particular run so this is kind of a cool
maneuver here and I'm really interested
to see where it goes but what this does
is it initially picks up with basically
Punisher Batman I'm calling him calling
I'm Punisher Batman because that's
basically what he is but the cool thing
about this is that this initially picks
up with like the death of Bruce Wayne's
family now of course this is kind of a
hallmark of the character it's like
Krypton exploding for Superman and the
idea is that under normal circumstances
in the main DC Universe Bruce Wayne
would just kind of left there right like
Joe Chill pulled the trigger killed his
parents and then ran and that was kind
of the end of that and then of course it
was Bruce Wayne basically saying like
I'm gonna swear vengeance so this never
has to happen on anybody else again or
anything along those lines but in this
instance this is not what happens
instead Bruce basically experiences like
this rush of anger and fear and in doing
so picks up the gun turns it on Joe
Chill and shoots him now this is kind of
a cool thing because what this does is
it sends him down the pathway of
becoming this dark and evil version of
Batman
now one of the important things to bear
in mind here is how this kind of feeds
into like the no kill rule right like
it's not really a hard and fast rule
it's not like it was established in a
particular comic that that man will kill
no more it was just kind of a gradual
series of events that led to a sort of
editorial decision made by DC that
Batman won't use guns anymore but the
overall gist in terms of why this exists
and how it was kind of explained with
regards to the Batman mythos was twofold
the first is that guns are so final you
pull a gun you shoot someone there's no
undoing that right like you can't come
back from that you can't undo it that's
Batman's perception but at the same time
the other reason why Batman really kind
of steers away from guns is because guns
kind of hold a particularly iconic role
in his life because that's what killed
his parents and so the idea so always
basically stay away from that concept
and then of course here's the role as
Batman to try to save as many people as
possible but following this whole thing
with his
as parents basically dying and him
shooting Joe Chill what he does is it
almost kind of mirrors Batman year one
by Frank Miller which is a retelling of
his origin in the post-crisis landscape
and so what you have here where he's
like breaking you know breaking bricks
and where he's like kicking a tree and
different things like that those are all
basically like homage to to Batman year
one those are scenes from that comic but
the kind of difference here is that
where all that training was done by
Batman traveling the world learning all
these different forms of martial arts
learning espionage and stealth and all
that kind of stuff training with like
ninja clans or different things like
that where all that was geared towards
using all that for the purpose of
instilling fear and then using that fear
to prevent a crew or to eliminate a
criminal element in Gotham this version
of Batman is using it to kill now again
one of the big ways they kind of pay
homage to the old Batman origin story is
that in that old story you had like a
bat that flew to the window right here
it's kind of one of those hallmark
moments of Batman's origin stories a bat
flies through the window and then it
crashes and then Bruce looks at it and
says yes Father you know I will become
fear I'll become Batman the same thing
kind of happens here except Bruce Wayne
shoots it and says that's the idea I'll
become fear I'll basically become a bat
in order to eliminate the criminal
element in Gotham and one of the first
things he does is he goes to like this
mob house and basically kills everyone
right like he literally like kicks over
this this fire stand of this fire pit
and then like burns the whole place down
and like burns all these people alive
it's cutthroat and so what this does is
it really kind of skips forward a little
bit but one of the things that the grim
Knights says is that there's really no
version of the Joker in the universe he
comes from but the reason why is because
in the early days of his criminal
element he killed the Joker at Ace
chemical that in the early days Batman
said essentially took out like the Red
Hood who would become the Joker
he took out Killer Croc he took out the
penguin all these different guys so you
took on all these different criminals
right in the very very early days and
what this is done or at least what it
did is it kind of turned him into an
extreme vigilante that was being tracked
down by the Gotham City Police
Department but in this instance where
he's a he's a pure like a pure
dyed-in-the-wool Killer is one of these
things were like the the the only real
constant concept here is the moral
incorrupt ability of Commissioner Gordon
it seems like in every single universe
as a commissioner gordon's in he all
he's always a good guy he always has
like this moral compass it's one thing
you can't betray you know you don't kill
people without without any kind of
recourse or anything like that but at
the same time it's actually a pretty
cool scenario because the great thing
about the Punisher Batman they
the great thing about the fact that he
kind of takes along to his own hands and
kills all these criminals is he's really
just kind of saying hey look the justice
system had the opportunity to ensure
these guys wouldn't be released again
but because the nature of the justice
system is all about giving second
chances what it does is it basically
says hey look yes you're criminals we're
gonna give you opportunities to continue
committing crime
Batman zarbor Batman stance is I'm
taking those opportunities away the
criminal justice system is basically a
means by which you can escape your guilt
and then in turn do the exact same thing
over again and they'll always be a
lawyer somewhere to get you off they're
not doing any good for anybody
and so it's a pretty cool concept here
and it actually works exceedingly well
and so what you literally have this
funny scenario where Commissioner Gordon
tries to draw Batman out and this is one
of the cool things about this he tries
to draw Batman out and in doing so
quote-unquote captures him well the
funny thing is is that Gordon basically
says like all this stuff is controlled
by Wayne Enterprises all the while never
realizing that the Batman that the grim
Knight is Bruce Wayne now this is one of
the big differences between the grim
Knight and the actual Batman from
mediate from the DC Universe because the
grim Knight exists to eliminate crime
everywhere he finds it and because he's
so effective at it he had to believe
that somewhere along the line criminals
would get their hands on Wayne teton
Wayne tech you know Wayne tech you know
weapons and equipment different things
like that it's a what better way to kind
of continue the war on that criminal
element and destroy it damn I basically
saying hey look we're effectively gonna
turn Wayne Enterprises tech into like a
two-way street that while they use it
for their own ends I can control it from
the back end and that's exactly what
happens using his access to Wayne
technology all the guards are taken out
like they're all alike all these cops
are eliminated on the spot that
literally like this this kind of fight
breaks out between Jim Gordon in Batman
but of course Batman basically ends up
making his escape and Jim Gordon's kind
of left with it with this information
that was kind of brought to his
attention or at least from the the
ramblings of the Batman who last that he
can essentially access Wayne technology
now putting two and two together because
Wayne technology is so advanced and
because when technology is not something
that's just easily accessible from the
back end what it means is the only one
who could really be able to access it is
Bruce Wayne and so what ends up
happening here is Commissioner Gordon
essentially draws the parallel he draws
a conclusion that Batman is Bruce Wayne
and in doing so basically says he's
public enemy number one for it for
Gotham City and where he goes to guys
like Rupert thorne who under normal
circumstances in the DC Universe are
villain
and where he goes to guys like two-face
who are usually villains but in this
instance are actually like mayor's you
know that they they hold powerful
positions in the city of Gotham but
they're not criminals because why would
you want to be a criminal in the city of
Gotham when he got Batman killing all
the criminals he finds but what he
basically you know what Commissioner
Gordon says is like we have to track
this guy down we have to capture Bruce
Wayne I've got the backing of the FBI
either you can join me in this or you
can be left behind as well as one of
those things where the critter that
element kind of stays hands off the FBI
shows up to Wayne Manor alongside
Commissioner Gordon and they basically
call Bruce Wayne out and it's kind of a
cool thing because like this knock-down
drag-out fight happens between the two
but it's kind of a funny scenario here
is because under normal circumstances
and it's it's sort of strange that it
works out this way under normal
circumstances
Commissioner Gordon should never been
able to get the upper hand on Bruce
Wayne because Bruce Wayne is just such
an effective fighter right like you know
hardcore Batman fans will say that's
ridiculous you know but my answer to
this is that most likely Commissioner
Gordon got the upper hand because he has
prep time you know I mean if prep time
works your Batman prep time works for
everything else and so Commissioner
Gordon gets the upper hand for you know
for a prep time I actually have no idea
that's the answer or not it's kind of
strange I mean technically speaking it
shouldn't really happen which is kind of
a an interesting concept an interesting
idea I'd really like to believe that one
of the one of the reasons why
Commissioner Gordon was kind of able to
get the upper hand on really the grim
Knight is because of the fact that the
grim Knight doesn't really rely on
stealth and and martial arts and things
like that in the same capacity that
Batman for the main DC Universe does
bitties more of just like a like a
broadsword right there just like this
this thing they just kind of SWAT you
know just swings and just is designed to
take out huge swathes of enemies whereas
the main DC Batman is more like a
scalpel he's more like surgical
precision that's kind of kind of his
whole MO and so that more likely more or
less more likely kind of seems to be the
way in which would happen but what it
did is it created a kind of animosity
between the grim Knight and Commissioner
Gordon the issue with this is that we're
not really told what happened with it
could with Commissioner Gordon in like
the dark multiverse we don't really know
what happened to it we don't know if he
died we don't know if like something
took place they kept the grim Knight
from being able to enact his revenge and
the reason why is because once he's here
he intends to basically enact revenge on
the main DC Commissioner Gordon that he
wanted to on the dark multiverse
Commissioner Gordon he associate wants
to like kill him on the spot but the
funny thing about this is that the
Batman who lasts basically says like
that's kind of pointless here we can do
much much worse to this guy
just killing if we kill him it's an easy
way out if we kill him then like he
doesn't suffer anymore but if you truly
want him to suffer then you give it time
let's implement our plan and let's bring
down everything around him it's kind of
a cool thing because what this does is
it sort of kind of hits to the idea that
what we could be seen is something akin
to like a return to The Killing Joke
right like we you see like Commissioner
Gordon being tortured with all these
images of his daughter being violated in
different things like that we don't
really know but without being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
rock war if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]